jake paul was caught again promoting a
scam and someone's going to jail
unfortunately it's not jake paul they
get back however it is a case we've done
in the past we called this way ahead of
time and i'm happy to say we're adding
another name to the hall of shame
scammers have been arrested after being
exposed on coffeezilla so stay tuned for
that but first we want to talk about
jake paul promoting an nft scam to fans
reportedly for 6.3 million
dollars and look i know
feels like groundhog day at this point
talking about jake paul and scams i mean
if you want to describe jake paul to
somebody you say he's an influencer
maybe first and then you might like i
was thinking about this you'd have to
say he's a scammer second boxer third he
technically has scammed more times than
he's boxed professionally in his life so
i don't know if he considers himself a
professional boxer but if he does he's
definitely a professional scammer more
than he is that
so look i get it it's exhausting
because we just keep catching him and he
keeps getting away with it sort of right
um just to briefly go over it we've
talked about stick dicks board bunny
apes in space safe moon yummy milf coin
sad boys
all of these scams or rug pools or some
kind of worthless going in this is how i
know it's getting to be too much for
everybody that last project sad boys
isn't even real i made it up on the spot
and
probably 90 of you didn't notice uh
because it's just as stupid as all the
others it just fits right in so i guess
i want to explain real quick why are we
covering this well i know it's easy to
get jaded about the fact that these
people very rarely face consequences
for their
actions
or scams um and that's why actually i
want to cover it i will cover jake paul
you know if you're gonna if you're gonna
promote scams i will expose you
until something happens so until
regulators until something happens
basically i don't care what until he
gets a slap on the wrist something we're
gonna keep covering it even though i
know we've been here before so today the
scam we're talking about is anna moon uh
he was caught promoting this it's like a
it's a pokemon knockoff it's just like
stealing money from people who are fans
of pokemon anyway here's the promotion
and moon team it's great to be a part of
this project i love the designs inspired
by pokemon the whole nine yards me
personally i'm gonna try to get a
legendary during the public mint but
y'all better not miss this all right so
he says two things there that are really
important one he's part of the project
which i think is really interesting he's
not saying i'm promoting it he's saying
i'm part of it
and two um he says it's inspired by
pokemon now this project is inspired by
pokemon the way the new ghostbusters is
inspired by the old ghostbusters it's
actually just a copy
that's worse here's the nfts in question
anna moon nfts they just recolored the
starter pokemon okay
charmander squirtle bulbasaur pikachu uh
they actually added supreme jerseys to
these pokemon others have visors or
masks on it just looks so stupid and
childish and you might naturally be
wondering who falls for this you know i
know jake paul is like the sleaziest
influencer promoter of all time and so
like who is actually buying this and
that's where it gets interesting because
one of the promises of this nft of the
legendary nfts was that they were going
to generate revenue every month
2500
every month it says right here on their
website which has now been deleted 15
cards are legendary cards that will be
automatically generating 2500 every
month for life
to their owners sort of a yang gang
style ubi if you get this
15 out of like 10 000 card and so you
can see why people thought it was a good
investment after all it only cost about
600 to mint each card and if you got one
of these legendaries you were kind of
set for life 2 500 a month is no joke
and so you can see why a lot of people
wanted to gamble and maybe try to
figure out if they could find one right
get one buy luck it's sort of like a
lottery ticket or something except of
course this was a scam because the
founders never went through with it this
is despite the fact they claim that they
have a signed nda with pokemon they say
that here they say they take a
percentage of the royalties but when
people ask for proof there was of course
none which just makes it even weirder
when jake paul says they were inspired
by pokemon and the project claims well
they're actually collaborating with
pokemon and then pokemons has nothing to
do with it make no mistake this was a
rug pull they promised the world they
promised pokemon partnerships and it was
all a lie and it ended up raking in 6.3
million dollars scammed from investors
so
that's the story there and at this point
you have to wonder with such a legacy of
promoting scam projects at what point is
someone gonna step in um and really kind
of crack down on this i know that's what
i was thinking and so it's what brought
me to my second story today which is of
somebody who got arrested after thinking
he could get away with it forever
because he had been getting away with it
you may remember this story it's about
open c which is an nft trading platform
i know we're pivoting a bit but it's all
going to tie in together so this is a
story we did a little while ago about a
guy named nate chastain who was one of
the executives at openc and because of
insider knowledge that he had about
these nfts that they were going to
launch every time they launched an nft
would explode in value on one of their
like promotion pages so nate would end
up insider trading on those nfts before
they hit the page because he knew they
were going to hit and he made a lot of
money this way and he got away with it
for a while well
right up until he didn't this just in
the doj charges former open c exec in an
insider trading scheme on the doj's
website they call this the first ever
digital asset insider trading scheme so
we are making history here and basically
nate is charged with one count of wire
fraud and one count of money laundering
because of this each of which carry a
maximum sentence of 20 years in prison
meaning nate could potentially face 40
years in prison because of this trading
scheme now of course he probably won't
get that maybe get 5 or 10 but it sets a
huge precedence for those who think they
can just keep getting away with it so
that's why i want to welcome nate to the
hall of shame which is a new segment
that we're introducing here today
he's going to join jay mazzini the other
influencer who went to jail for for
these schemes so um can we just get a
little moment of silence for these two
[Music]
rest in pieces boys so in conclusion
guys i know it looks bleak i know it
looks like these guys just get away with
scheme after scheme but eventually
after catching you multiple times
eventually you may pay the price uh so
hats off to you nate for joining the
hall of shame and uh that's basically it
i'll see you in the next one